foreign
should we welcome the return of an
object of morality
or is it
authoritarian fantasy I'm going to start
with slavoy
very briefly I hope I will have some
cleanse later to go on I I first it all
depends on what you mean by objective
morality and moral relativism of I think
there is a third term here if I may even
refer briefly to a philosopher with whom
I didn't agree Carl popper you know he
introduced the term of the third world
like
objective facts of a symbolic order
which in some sense are not part of
external reality but nonetheless it's
false to subjectivize them to say these
are just emotions and so on in this
sense I think
morality to work as morality has to be
minimally objective you cannot have
morality which for which you claim that
it directly just expresses your
attitudes your whatever but just to give
two three things into what direction I
want to go there are big historical
changes but I think that although there
are many rules which in some way or
other are common to
different epochs what always fascinated
me is that every objective system of not
just morality but customs and so on
always relies on Unwritten implicit
Unwritten rules which are absolutely
crucial and I will conclude with just
two examples which are my favorite one
is did you notice how often
things are prohibited
but the system itself between the lines
solicits you to violate the prohibition
like I had a very vulgar experience
sorry to fall so low with my father when
I was young he warned me against
contacts to Young with women and so on
and then he inquired but did you already
do it what kind of a man are you and so
on so following you know this ambiguity
and much more interesting with which I
will conclude the opposite version of
things that we are solicited even to do
you can do it on condition that you
don't
do it for example my favorite ick okay
ordinary and extreme example then I stop
ordinary example do you have I'm not
talking about the traitors England here
in Wales do you also have this manner I
invite you to dinner
and it's clear that I will pay but when
the bill arrives I
if I invited you you have to insist for
some time no no let's hear it and so on
we both know that at the end I will pay
but the guy has to make an offer which
we know will be refused and my favorite
example here is it really happened in
sorry old stalinist Soviet Union in
Soviet Union it was not only of course
prohibited to criticize Stalin it was
even more prohibited to publicly
announce this prohibition
it happened at one session that the guy
raised canned comrade Stalin is wrong
here then another guy raised his hand
and said are you crazy we don't speak
like this here you don't criticize
Stalin the second guy disappeared much
faster than the first one you know this
is very elegant thing prohibition itself
is prohibited all this just to
complicated things thanks
brilliant that does complicate things
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas